Guys, do I just want to start this off
and say that I absolutely love Nvidia
GPUs. Four
elephants, one GPU. They are so amazing.
I mean, just look in here. Look at the
reflections. You can see the ray trace
reflections in the game. The ray trace
shadows. Everything looks so sharp. You
can see these people in the reflections.
It looks so cool. And at the same time,
we're upscaling from 1080p up to 4K.
DLSS upscaling is just a huge, huge
feature. Like, look how good it looks.
Would you ever complain about how this
looks? And all at the same time, we're
using these technologies and everything
and we're getting a solid
100fps or 110 113 FPS.
Wait, who the put an AMD GPU in my
system? This is not
Nvidia. This is not
Nvidia. My cat's he he doesn't get it
either. What the hell is that? I think
he put in my system. He's probably the
schemer.
that Nvidia markets their graphics cards
on. I mean, they rely on the rateracing
performance. They rely on the upscaling
performance. You know, you see all the
Nvidia marketing, but AMD is holding up
so so well here on this new GPU. It is
so good. I'm so happy that I managed by
the grace of Lord Steve, shut the
up, to get this 9070 XT. I bought this
day one at MSRP of $600 from
MicroEnter. It smells awful. I didn't
smell it.
Smells like my shoes. By the way, it
smells okay now. And the more and more
that I use it, when I'm not just like
benchmarking all the time with this
giant spreadsheet, when I've actually
been able to play with the graphics
card, I've really enjoyed these
features. They've been super super nice.
I played Space Marine 2 on performance
mode upscaling, which is really
aggressive upscaling, and I was
completely happy with the way that the
game looked and the performance I was
getting out of the GPU. So, it really
got me thinking, what is the point of an
Nvidia GPU anymore? Now, guys, we know
that AMD has had the best raw gaming
performance value, and that still holds
true to this day. Like, here is a brief
compilation of the 9070 XT beating the
$1,000, or more like how it's looking on
the market right now, the
$1,400 RTX 5080. That's not always the
case. I mean, typically the 5080 is
quite a bit faster, but I just wanted to
show you like this car can present some
really, really good value, especially
for that price, and you know, I have
on RTX 5070 Ti quite a bit. Nvidia
only compared this to the 4070 Ti in
their official marketing, even though
there is a 4070 Ti Super. That should
have been the actual comparison to this
5070 Ti, but I honestly think that
Nvidia was scared about comparing it to
the Ti Super because of how poor the
performance uplift is to that card. I
mean, in most games, it's only like 10
to 15% faster than the 4070 Ti Super.
These are going for about the same
price. They had the same amount of VRAM
and all that kind of stuff. They're only
a year apart. Then stacking on top of
this guys, I mean, the freaking prices,
this card is like
$970 at the lowest price range. $1,000.
This is supposed to be a
$750 graphics card. The MSRP just does
not exist, guys. And well, well, well,
look at this. The 9070 XT and raw gaming
performance, meaning rasterized
performance, not ray tracing. This is
the overall average of what I tested,
and everything's at native on these
tests, so no upscaling and stuff. These
cards are close on average. I mean,
they're just within a couple percent of
each other, but the 1% lows are 23%
slower on the 5070 Ti, which means it's
stuttering much more in the games, less
consistent performance. This isn't like
a VRAM related thing. AMD is offering
the same 16 GB of memory. is GDR6
instead of GR7 on the 570Ti. So, I'm
thinking these stutters that are on the
570Ti are most likely caused by the
software on the GPU, aka the driver that
everybody claims Nvidia's amazing
drivers, right? But we can look in a
game like Kingdom Come Deliverance 2.
This is an Nvidia favored game. Nvidia
GPUs usually trounce AMD ones in this.
The 5070 Ti wins on average by 10%.
which makes sense, but actually it is a
more stuttery experience because it
loses by 10% in the 1% lows. And in Last
of Us Part One, the 5070 Ti is actually
slightly ahead on average, but it loses
by 18% in the 1% lows. And you can make
this out by the spikes on the frame time
graph. The 9070 XT is rock solid and is
not the only thing that's rock solid, if
you know what I'm saying. Here's the
thing. Marvel Rivals is the same story.
However, they perform virtually
identical on average in this game. But
again, you look how stuttery the 5070 Ti
in this game, and it really doesn't look
that good. It's just a common trend that
shows up on at least this Nvidia
graphics card, this 50 series card. I
usually don't have these issues on
Nvidia cards, neither with AMD cards.
These are on the exact same PC. The
launch drivers that were publicly
available to everybody. It isn't like
some kind of review driver, beta drive.
And these are the results that I got
with it. Now, it gets me a little bit
worried and I might want to retest it at
some point because it just seems really
bad. But I just wanted to let you know
that yes, it's getting all these
stutters and stuff and I don't exactly
know why it's happening. And the fact
that someone like me who tests GPUs all
the time, if I didn't catch a mistake on
this, that doesn't exactly bode well for
the QC problems that are on Nvidia
graphics cards at the moment. I'm not
going to talk about it anymore. The 5070
Ti, the more important thing is it's 25%
more expensive, but it doesn't always
even win on average. So, in Cyberpunk at
4K high settings, it's 5% slower. In
Black Ops 6, at competitive balanced
settings, the 5070Ti is 12% slower. This
is a very AMD favorite game, so take
that into account, but there's Nvidia
favorite games, too, that we already
went over. Also, it loses by 12% in
Allen Wake 2. Important to note, too,
that the 9070 XT is getting very close
to 60fps at native 4K. If you turn on a
little bit of upscaling, the 9070 XT
also stretches its legs as the 5070Ti
continues to struggle. And in Remnant 2,
5070Ti is 9% slower in that game, too.
So, AMD is offering some really, really
great value on this 9070 XT compared to
the 5070Ti. Even in rateracing, the 9070
XT is presenting great value. And let me
show you why. In Plague Reququum RT
Shadows, it's a pretty light form of ray
tracing. At 1440p, the 9070 XT actually
wins against the 5070 Ti. And the same
story is at 4K as well. We move over to
Cyberpunk, which is ray trace
reflections in the game at 1440p. The
5070Ti is 23% ahead, which sounds like a
lot, but is a lot better than what AMD
used to do with rateracing this game.
And I'll show you that in just a second.
But the 970 XT does actually win if you
turn on a little bit of upscaling, but
this is using DLSS4, whereas this is
still FSR3 on this version of the game.
So the 970 XT doesn't look as good.
Where things get rough though with
rateracing if you make it really, really
heavy ray tracing. Like in rateracing
Overdrive in Cyberpunk, the 5070Ti leaps
41% ahead of 970 XT. In blacksmith
Wukong, it is actually running laps
around the 970 XT 110% faster. And Allen
Wake 2 with 1440p with upscaling, the
5070Ti is actually playable at
57fps whereas the 9070 XT is not. So
even though there's only a 30% gap here,
the the 5070Ti you can actually play the
game on this. And I think that is a
pretty big advantage. So, it seems like,
and this is a pretty common trend with
everything, the more that you load up
ray tracing features, the heavier you
make it, the 9070 XT will fall more and
more behind. It's probably because the
overall rate tracing performance on the
GPU isn't as strong as a 5070Ti, but it
is still a lot faster than the older
cards. And that's where we can see that
AMD has made a massive, massive leap
with rateracing performance. Just look
at this GPU against the 7800 XT. This
was a $500 GPU that AMD released last
gen. It was in 2023. It actually wasn't
really that long ago. Normal rasterized
gaming performance is a massive 42%
faster, which gives you an idea of how
far this new GPU does come ahead that
for $100 more is 42% faster. That's
pretty big. If we hop over to rateracing
on the average, it's 92% faster in ray
tracing versus their older card, which
is similarly speced in Allen Wake 2. If
we look at the 7800 XT, could you even
call this a rate tracing GPU? I don't
really know. Also, the 7800 XT is down
bad in Blackmth Wukong. 970 XT is
actually committing war crimes in this
game versus their older card. It had a
huge huge blow up. Just ray trace
reflections in Cyberpunk destroys the
7800 XT. And this does continue cuz
the 9070 XT beats even their last
generation $1,000 flagship, the 7900 XTX
GPU. Now, in normal raster performance,
the XTX is a little bit ahead, but
really not that much. It does have 24 GB
of VRAM versus 16 GB on the 970 XT, but
uh we'll see how much that actually
matters because the Seven XTX is 22%
behind in RA tracing on average. And
this shows in every single test. The 970
XT is just ahead of their older card. So
AMD is bringing their flagship
rateracing performance. I mean
admittedly their rateracing performance
still wasn't very good, but they're
bringing that down to $600. And that's
what brings me to what GPU we should
actually be comparing the 9070 X-T2.
This is all striking above its weight
class. The 970 XT is only a $600 card at
MSRP, which we'll be talking about the
prices pretty soon here as well. Yeah,
the XTX was $1,000. I mean, the 5070Ti
is $750 and generally speaking, it's
going for like over $900 on the real
market right now. So, what if we compare
it to the
RTX 4070 Super?
Now, this card actually was $600, but
that's not the reason I'm comparing it
to. And we're not going to talk about
the the pricing that we're seeing right
now at like $930 for this GPU.
Apparently, you can still buy it. And if
we look at hardware and boxes data, we
can see the 4070 Super is right here
with RTX 5070, which is basically a 4070
Super Duper. These cards are basically
the same. Now, the 5070 is a $550 GPU.
Not really that you could actually buy
the 5070 at $550. Now, the reason I show
you guys the 4070 Super and not the 4070
Super Duper is because Nvidia actually
didn't send me the 5070 because I think
I've been on them a lot lately
and they didn't put me on the priority
and apparently they ran out of cards to
send people. So, if you imagine the 4070
Super is basically just a 5070 down
there and that means the 9070 XT is
technically only 9% more expensive at
MSRP. as much as that's really not true
at the moment. And everything that I
test, well, native, not not with
upscaling, but the 970 XT for 9% more
money is 21%
faster overall. And if you break it
down, it's 31% faster in rasterized
performance, which I think that's the
performance most people care about right
now, though ray tracing is a little bit
more future-looking. Now, they're
actually pretty close in terms of rate
tracing performance, but we're going to
go into that in a second because 43%
faster in God of War Ragnarok. How about
45% faster in Horizon Forbidden West?
Now, it's only 20% faster at Indiana
Jones, but notice that the 1% lows in
this game are 40% ahead on the 9070 XT.
And that's probably because the 970 XT
has 16 gigabytes of VRAM whereas the
4070 Superra or the 5070 if you want to
just call it that only has 12 GB of
VRAM. Like Nvidia just malnourish this
graphics card. It is so anemic at this
point in time. Now if we hop over to
Last of Us part one, it's a massive 50%
and 82% on the uplifts here. Probably
mostly because of that VRAMm difference
as well. And you can see all the
stutters happening on the 4070 Super.
Now things can ease up a little bit if
you drop the resolution scale by using
some upscaling in the game. This game
does support DLSS4 and FSR4 which is
really really cool to see. 97 XT is only
19% faster in this case. So things even
out a little bit now. It's 28% faster in
the Nvidia favored game Kingdom Come
Deliverance 2, which isn't really VRAM
limited a ton, though it can get a
little bit up there. Now 41% faster in
Remnant 2. that game doesn't use that
much VRAM and it's just kind of nuts how
much the 97 XT just destroys that card
in this game. Now, on the ray tracing
performance in the later titles, like as
we talked about before, Cyberpunk with
just reflections, the 970 XT is pretty
far ahead actually and a significant
improvement just for $50 more dollars on
the AMD graphics card here, which is not
something we would ever say before. It's
really weird. And the same goes for
Plague Recquum. Just rate trace shadows
in this game. The same thing in Ratchet
and Clank Rift Apart. You can get all
the way up to 60 fps at native 4K in
this test here. Just ignore the 4070
super percentages. I I messed that up.
But the weirdness happens when you get
over to the heavy ray tracing titles
like RT Overdrive in Cyberpunk. The 970
XT actually falls behind the 4070 Super.
Hop over to Blacksmith Wukong and this
game just loves Nvidia. Like no matter
how weak the Nvidia graphics card is.
Yeah, even with rateracing, it just the
AMD card can't compete. Now in Allen
Wakeake 2, they end up getting pretty
damn close in this game. The thing about
rate tracing on the 5070 or the 4070
Super, whatever the heck you want to
call this card, the VRAMm is an issue.
That 12 GB when you turn on rate
tracing, you get increased VRAM usage.
And in games like Indiana Jones, I
couldn't even test this game with ray
tracing, like the heavier forms of rate
tracing. You can't even run this at
native
1440p. So, I could only test this with
DLSS quality, which still ran terribly
cuz it was still VRAMm limited. it just
wasn't crashing at that point. And I was
able to test it with DLSS performance at
1440p. So basically on the 4070 Super,
you could only run this card by
upscaling from 720p in this game. And
this would be a brand new $550 graphics
card that costs more than a PS5. And
this means if you want to get out of
this 12 GB trap that Nvidia's set
everyone in, Tony is scratching my leg.
Nvidia is going to make you spend $750
plus, you know, we're seeing the price
right now on a 5070, you know, Ti if you
want to get 16 GB of VRAM or they're
going to release a 5060 Ti that has 16
GB, but that card is going to be weaker
and then it won't really justify the
more VRAM as much as the 5070 actually
does. The AMD graphics card with the
more VRAM is just getting more and more
useful to this day. And that brings me
into FSR4 because the upscaling is a
massive component of these GPUs. Once
every game is defaulting to turning
upscaling on and we see games like
Monster Hunter Wilds, god forbid, it
runs like total Yeah,
you're going to probably have to upscale
on that game. Maybe not on this graphics
card cuz it's a very fast graphics card.
I didn't test it in this game personally
cuz it takes forever to benchmark. Just
so many games are requiring upscaling to
be functional nowadays. So FSR4 is a
huge deal. Now, DLSS has been the goat
when it comes to upscaling, and the
newest DLSS4 Transformer model just
looks even better. I want you to tell me
by looking at these sidebyside footage,
which one is FSR4 and which one is
DLSS4? We're in Remnant 2 right now.
We're at 1440p on the quality mode. So,
this is upscaling from about 1080p up to
1440p. I want you to pay attention to
the fine detail and stuff. Can you see
the difference between these two? I can
go ahead and slow it down so you can get
a little bit more time to look at these
things as they pass by. I mean, shoot.
I'll go ahead and zoom in on it and you
can really see what the hell is
happening here. How about we check this
out in Space Marine 2. It supports the
LSS4 and FSR4 in this game as well. And
if you're struggling to see the
difference between these two, like don't
worry. If I didn't have these labeled in
software, I would be too. FSR4. The
reason it can look this good is because
it's also using deep learning or AI
magic with their upscaler. And it's
accelerated by the new AI hardware
that's on AMD's brand new GPUs. By the
way, if you're wondering, the left side
was FSR4 on quality mode this whole
time. The right side was DLSS4. Were you
right on your predictions and stuff? If
you were to see these running in motion,
can you tell? Now, I personally find
that FSR4 always looks better than DLSS
3. So, the older version of DLSS that a
lot of people are still very happy with
the image quality on. And then on top of
that, I only find that DLSS4 looks
better than FSR4 in like very niche
cases. Like it it always looks better
than FSR4, but not that much that I
don't think a lot of people would be
able to tell what the hell is happening
here and actually be able to register
and it matter in real time when you're
just playing a game. as I played Space
Marine 2 with FSR4 on performance mode
on this GPU. Got great performance and
thought the game looked absolutely
phenomenal as well. But FSR4 does have
some flaws. And the first thing is the
game support. This is usually done by
using the driver, the AMD driver to
override the games, which is the same
thing that Nvidia is doing with their
DLSS4 technology for the most part. But
these are the only games that do. Not
all of them are the biggest games out.
Mostly a bunch of Sony ports. or Marvel
Rivals supports FSR4, but I wasn't able
to get it running in this game. But
what's weird is it apparently told me
that I was able to get it running in
Stalker 2, but Stalker 2 doesn't support
FSR4 at the moment. So, I don't even
know if the tests that I did in that
were actually real or not. The reason
why not that many games support FSR4
right now is because of an oversight
that AMD made quite a while ago is they
didn't really look very forwardlooking
with their technology. They had FSR 3,
FSR 2, FSR1. they didn't consolidate all
these things into a DLL file that you
could actually modify in the game files.
Whereas Nvidia did that and even Intel
did that with their upscaler as well.
AMD only with FSR 3.1 which came out in
like fall of 2024. Only games that
support 3.1 can be upgraded through the
driver straight up to FSR4 with no
hitches whatsoever. So, also another
flaw with FSR4 is that same thing. Like
AMD wasn't really looking forward on
their other GPUs, and their older GPUs,
as far as I can tell, aren't going to
support FSR4. The backwards
compatibility just isn't there because
the older cards don't have enough AI
performance in order to do that. Yet,
Nvidia will also randomly lock features
to their newer graphics cards as well,
like multi-frame generation or even DLSS
3 frame generation. Back when 40 series
came out, AMD should have probably been
working on AO upscaling for quite a
while and considered it in their GPU
architecture, but they didn't. And we
don't know if it's going to come to
these older GPUs. And the last problem
with FSR4 is actually more major than
the other ones that I just mentioned,
the FPS or the performance uplift you're
actually getting from upscaling. Cuz as
we know, upscaling, it ups your FPS and
it can also take care of anti-aliasing
at the same time in games. And that's
usually why we end up using it. through
my tests at the 970 XT with quality
upscaling compared to native rendering
in the game, it only got me 26% more FPS
when I was upscaling at 4K. Whereas, if
you take a look at the 4070 Super on
DLSS4 got me 53% more performance. Now,
I will say that this was the 4070 Super
and is at 4K. So, the VRAM, it only
having 12 GB and then being alleviated
with upscaling a little bit maybe could
be a reason why it had a higher uplift.
But this is generally what I see is you
get more percentage increases by using
DLSS. Not only does DLSS look better
with DLSS4, but it's also getting more
performance. And that's kind of a, you
know, a one two knockout kind of punch
that AMD like I don't doubt that this
FSR4 can get better because DLSS got a
lot lot better over time. But you're
buying it and you're using it for what
it is right now and you don't know when
those updates are going to come or even
if they're going to come in the future
at all. Now granted with these tests,
this is just a 9070 XT. This is just a
4070 Super. It's just that what I have
experienced with the cards, at least so
far. Now, on the other side, AMD's video
encoders have just been really
inefficient and honestly pretty shitty
for a while. But with this new
generation, they have massively improved
their video encoding support. Now, EPOS
Fox made a very, very great video about
this. If you want to take a look at it,
I'll link it in the description. That's
what gets me wondering. You know, all
these features adding up, the rate
tracing performance being improved to a
point where you might turn it on like
you would never turn it on before on an
AMD GPU. FSR4 is doing very very well.
You got this better price to
performance, better VRAM at that price
point as well. The codecs are better for
video encoding. The software adrenaline
AMD software is really good as well.
This AMD GPU, I mean, they kind of
cooked with this one. I'm not going to
lie. I'm not going to lie. So, what are
the downsides to getting this GPU? You
know, that mind share. That's the reason
why they have to be so aggressive on
pricing is because uh people need to
look at this GPU over an Nvidia GPU. And
right now, Nvidia is eroding a lot of
their trust and get a lot of people
looking at their GPUs, especially when
it holds up so goddamn well. But some of
the issues that can crop up with the AMD
cards is their software support. Now,
the Adrenaline software is good, but if
you want to do like AI programming and
and things like Blender and stuff for 3D
modeling or you're going to run into
compatibility problems even today, but
for most mainstream things, you're
probably not going to have any issues
and the average person isn't going to
run into anything. I will tell you that.
That's my experience. And the other
thing is the stock situation. Now, if we
do actually look, you still can't really
buy a 9070 XT. I mean, I got really,
really lucky. I got it for MSRP because
I went day one to MicroEnter. MicroEnter
just happened to have the entire world
stock. Now, what I have heard from AMD,
I did ask them and basically they told
me what they've been telling everybody
in the public. Apparently, this isn't
going to be the price. Like, they're not
trying to fake the MSRP, but we're still
yet to see this happening and then being
available at MSRP, but is not apparently
their stated goal. And really, with
that, it's time will tell. The thing
about it and what I think AMD has to
fear, and you guys might hate me for
saying this, but the 5070 Ti, so that's
going for like, you know, stupid stupid
money right now. So the 5070 Ti like
$1,000 pretty much at the moment. Not
really that great. But the thing is that
this card does beat the 970 XT in terms
of rateracing performance. It usually
does beat it in rasterized performance
as well. So, you're basically, if it's
MSRP versus MSRP, it's only $150 more to
get DLSS support, get all the software
support, get the better rate tracing. Is
if Nvidia does get their prices down to
MSRP, and if AMD even gets their price
down to MSRP, I'm not sure if the 97 XT
is going to sell all that well compared
to the Nvidia card. Yeah, AMD might have
had a great launch and they sold it very
well. How is that going to continue in
the future? Are they going to have to
discount the 970 XT? I don't even know
if they can because I feel like that
price is already very very aggressive
and same with the 5070. The only real
problem with the 5070 of its VRAMm
capacity. I mean, the price is actually
pretty good and the value for
performance isn't really that bad
either, especially against AMD's cheaper
9070. Right now, 97 XT, I mean, I really
like it. I've been enjoying it quite a
bit. Let me know what you guys think on
this. I'm going to have a bunch of
follow-up videos. I have so many goddamn
sidebysides edited and rendered out. Um,
I really want to do some longer
head-to-head through the test so you
guys can see everything that I see.
Peace, guys. Have a good one. Tony says,
"Peace out." He's shedding all over my
desk, so I'm going to have to clean this
up. But have a good one.
[Music]